- And I said, hey,
unless you're out and about
with the goddamned
Dave Matthews Band,
you better get your ass home,
'cause shit's about to go down
at Ma and Pa's house.
[dark electronic music]
♪ ♪
- Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
[chatter]
- [burps]
- I'm your host, Roy Wood, Jr.
Hey, there you go, boys.
Drink up.
Nobody's gonna remember what
the hell's happening tonight.
That dude's trying
to get my couch pregnant.
He peeing out the window.
- [retches]
- C'mon, man.
John Legend
bought me that piano.
[crowd cheers]
Who brought a ball pit?
- [screams]
[crowd gasps]
- [groans triumphantly]
[crowd cheers]
♪ ♪
- You know him from
his one-hour special on Hulu,
"Ugly and Angry,"
Chris Porter, everybody.
[electronic music]
[crowd cheers]
- I put my dad through
a lot of shit.
And this story is about that.
I never put him
through much as a kid.
But as an adult,
when I come home,
where I haven't
lived for 12 years,
it's a bit of an event.
And we like to party.
And sometimes my dad gets
caught up in the crossfire.
Through a bunch
of weird experiences,
I've become friends
with Justin Verlander,
who's a pitcher
for the Detroit Tigers.
Yeah, he's not--he's not here.
Um...
The Tigers were in town
playing the Royals.
And, uh, they had a night off.
So Justin and I went out
for some drinks.
While we were out, he said,
hey, man, I think I know that
girl over there.
I think she's an actress.
I'm pretty sure
my girlfriend and I saw her
in a movie last month.
I should go get
my picture taken with her,
send it to my girlfriend.
I said, hey, man,
we're in Kansas City.
No fucking way
that chick's an actress.
He said, nah, man.
He calls the waiter over.
He said,
who's the chick over there?
He goes, man,
I don't know who the chick is,
but everyone at that table is
with Mumford & Sons.
They're here playing
the arena tomorrow night.
And they're here having dinner.
Justin says,
well, send them a bottle on us.
Meaning him, right?
I'm not paying for that shit,
okay?
A: Not a huge
Mumford & Sons fan.
B: When I hang out
with super rich people,
I don't pay for shit, okay?
Sorry, you fly private.
You're buying my shit.
All right?
If he pays for my shit,
it doesn't even show up
on his register.
If I pay for my shit,
I can't buy shoes next month,
and I'm gonna be pissed.
So he sends them a bottle.
They come over
to say thank you.
Turns out,
it's not Mumford & Sons.
It's just "& Sons."
All right?
I don't know where Mumford was,
but he wasn't there.
I assume he was back
at the hotel
writing a song that at
some point goes,
[vocalizes]
"Ah-ah--ah."
So, "& Sons" come over.
Start talking to
the Detroit Tigers.
I'm not really involved,
so I kinda tune it out.
When I come back into focus,
Ampersand Sons are talking shit
to the Detroit Tigers
about beer pong.
Like they're like, hey, we'll
whoop your ass
at some beer pong.
And the Detroit Tigers
are like,
we get paid very handsomely
to put balls places...
Fuckin' bring it.
So I said, hey, fellas.
My parents live about
eight minutes from here.
We could settle this.
And I said that
because I know full well
that both "& Sons"
and the Detroit Tigers
have a complete foyer
at both of their hotels
where they can do whatever
the fuck they wanna do.
So there's no reason to come
to my parents' house.
It was complete,
fake hospitality.
Until they turned around
and said, fuck yeah!
Let's go to your parents' house
to play beer pong.
Aw, shit!
It's 1:30 on a Sunday night,
technically Monday morning.
My parents aren't Gypsies,
all right?
They got real jobs,
with real responsibilities
that start in about four hours.
But I also can't look
at these dudes, and be like,
you guys, my parents.
So I just said, fuck it.
Let's roll the dice,
and see what happens.
So we start leaving.
About the time
we're heading out,
my sister texts me,
and says,
hey, I'm out and about.
If you get home before I do,
will you walk my dog?
And I said, hey,
unless you're out and about
with the goddamned
Dave Matthews Band,
you better get your ass home,
'cause shit's about to go down
at Ma and Pa's house.
So we roll into my parents'
house, like 12 deep
and start throwing beer pong,
and shit got weird.
Like, weirder than
I've already described.
Like, my sister, who's 30,
ended up in her prom dress.
Like--I don't know.
I don't know how that happened.
God bless her for still being
able to fit in it.
But also, the fuck, right?
So...
At one point in the evening,
I decided I needed to step out
and smoke some weed.
"& Sons" come with me.
But since it was
the middle of the season,
the Detroit Tigers
could not partake,
so they had to pretend like it
was the playoffs, and watch.
[crowd groans and laughs]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[laughter and applause]
Thank you.
So we come back in
from smoking weed.
My dad's downstairs,
and he's pissed.
Apparently,
while we were outside,
we got a little loud,
woken Mom and Dad up.
So, I walk inside.
Dad's like,
the fuck's going on?
I said, hey, Dad, uh--
That's "& Sons,"
of Mumford & Sons.
And this is half
the Detroit Tigers' bullpen.
And we're playing beer pong.
And it was in this moment that
I realized that my dad
was not incredibly sure
if he was actually awake.
You gotta look at it
from a dad's point of view.
He walks downstairs
in the middle of the night,
sees a bunch of weird dudes
that he kinda recognizes,
and my sister's
in her prom dress.
All right?
Shit's weird.
Dad's obviously befuddled.
He's just like:
[stammering]
Uh, is that
fuckin' Justin Verlander?
Yes, sir, it is.
And he just went,
ah--whatever.
And he just
went back upstairs.
And that was the last
we saw of him.
The whole next day
I'm freaking out.
He's at work.
I obviously slept in.
My parents have done
a lot for me over time.
I can't be fucking up
like this.
So I gotta make amends.
So, I'm like, I'm gonna
take him out to dinner.
I'm gonna buy him drinks.
I'm gonna do good by him.
But then Dad walks in the door
like he's had the greatest day
of his goddamned life.
He walks in like,
[imitates door slamming open]
What's up, everybody?
How are you doing?
[imitates laser gunshot]
All right.
I looked and I go,
the hell happened to you today?
He said, I fucking hated you
this morning.
I woke up on four hours' sleep.
And I cursed your name
all the way to work.
But then I got to work,
and we had our morning meeting.
And everyone started asking me
why I looked
so tired and exhausted,
and I started bitching
about my kids
bringing home
Detroit Tigers,
and Mumford & Sons,
and playing beer pong
all night.
Now I'm the coolest
motherfucker in the office.
You guys have been
a lot of fun.
Thank you so much.
-  Chris Porter, everybody.
[cheers and applause]